vous êtes bourgi ment vous êtes franc
comtois vous pensez connaître la région
sur le bout de vos doigts bien c'est
votre point de vue nous on va vous
présenter quelqu'un qui va vous faire
sortir des sentiers battus ici à bonjour
maeva bienvenue à bord vous observez
koala une statue à trompe l'oeil statut
mais c'est surtout un puits et sa cacher
une pompe tout simplement est là on est
dans plein coeur de beaune à boni a
plein de surprises quand il y en a plein
vous emmène rognard pascal est un
greeter comprenez haute en anglais sa
passion faire découvrir bonne à sa façon
une visite assurée bénévolement et
garantis 100% atypique parce que vous
m'avez pour vous porter restant s'est
battu mais la place cardon c'est la
place la plus connue de vol oui
évidemment on est obligé d'y passer
mais quand on est gris tort on a des tas
d'autres choses je vous emmène on va où
ah la la goutte de lait
[Musique]
alors ici on arrive dans un endroit un
peu secret une cour que les touristes
fréquentent pas ça s'appelle la goutte
de lait pourquoi la goutte de lait c'est
simplement parce que pendant la guerre
de 1870
bon il y avait des famines etc les
hospices ont décidé de distribuer des
petites bouteilles de lait alors c'était
du lait de vache parce que le suisse
possède aussi des fermes et c est donc
ces distributions pour les femmes qui
allaitaient s'est faite de 1870 à 1974
1974 et là on retrouve bien le rôle en
fait dead et de l'aide aux plus
malheureux des hospices parce qu'elle
j'ai trouvé un autre fut oui alors
toujours intuit en avait partout à
l'époque est en fête et dessus voyez
c'était bizarre alors la légende dit que
c'est un mouton
j'ai tendance à y croire et le mouton
s'appelait le robot en bourgogne et on
dit que le mot robinet viendrait de là
alors je ne sais pas si c'est vrai mais
j'adore cette anecdote est lourde la
reprend être greeter c'est avant tout un
état d'esprit parce qu'elle n'a pas le
statut de guide touristique
la visite qu'il propose se destine avant
tout aux curieux de nature en quête de
partage c'est toujours une conversation
une balade avec un greeter on est de 2 à
6 maximum et on échange et en fonction
de ceux de ce dont on parle et dont on
va voir une chose une autre c'est
exactement comme si on était avec des
amis en fait pas ciel vous menez sur le
parking de l'hôpital
ben c'était l'hôpital jusque dans les
années 60 c'était l'hôpital de beaune
les auspices là on à l'arrière des
hospices ici c'était la maternité
et puis ben on va aller dans un endroit
que les gens connaissent moins bien
et oui c'est les entrées secrètes les
hospices de beaune accueille 450 mille
visiteurs par an son arrière-cour est
libre d'accès et pourtant personne ne
s'y aventurent un endroit secret qui
abrite un jardin d'exception
mais notre présence n'a pas échappé à
l'oeil averti d'un touriste vous êtes
allé d alors je vous ai vu dans les
cours avant un oui mais nous on est
passé par une entrée 5 euros à l'arrêt
je vais vous montrer un petit truc si
vous avez le temps il faudra faire un
petit tour sur les sur les remparts de
volnay voir robin puis s'est ouvert en
plus longs la votre chance c'est ouvert
vous pourriez solliciter un greeter
pourquoi pas oui si l'on sait où
séjourna directement sur internet alors
attaquant victor et puis vous tapez
beaune dijon du singe en actes
et puis même manière c'est super bien
cette passion anime pascal depuis 2014
il assure seize visites par an